well this film was terrific
it's getting a ton of Oscar buzz I think
it's gonna win I think you guys are
gonna win how are we feeling fitting
speeches are we just are we how far are
we into this
no I don't think anywhere close to that
we have the most beautiful we got to
play at the Chinese Theater last night
Steven introduced the film in the most
beautiful way talking about his editor
of 35 years John Williams's composer of
50 years I think Michelle luckily
reminded me last night to take a moment
and like just appreciate where we are
because we're fortunate that we got to
have this experience and now get to
share this film yeah yeah are you
excited how are you feeling about all
this
I feel good I feel great I I feel
um
I am still pinching myself I really kind
of can't believe that this is where I am
and this is who I'm sitting with and
this is who I'm talking about this is
like Beyond a dream come true yeah your
role was quite heavy there was a lot of
emotional scenes what was that like
off camera
I think honestly it's it's only a gift
like I never I couldn't look at this any
other way it's only a gift it's only a
joy
um like I said beyond any any dream I
could have dreamed so I I treasured each
and every moment
thank you for your time yeah thank you
so much